er molas o será el nuevo presidente de
ecuador en su tercer intento por llegar
al palacio de carondelet el banquero de
guayaquil que representa la derecha
tradicional ocupará la presidencia del
país andino a partir del 24 de mayo y
mantendrá la ruta de las políticas
abiertas al mercado gracias desde el
fondo del alma desde el fondo de mi
corazón por darme la oportunidad de ser
su presidente hoy es un día de
celebración la democracia ha triunfado
los ecuatorianos todos ustedes han usado
su derecho a elegir por su parte el
candidato correcta en esta segunda
vuelta
andrés zarautz reconoció la victoria del
ac y lo felicito
este es un traspié electoral pero de
ninguna manera es una derrota política
ni moral
luego de estas declaraciones de prensa
realizaré una llamada telefónica al
señor guillermo lasso le le felicitaré
por el triunfo electoral obtenido el día
de hoy también el ex presidente rafael
correa asumió los resultados
no es un final sino un comienzo ha dicho
andrés gracias a todos por su apoyo
sinceramente creíamos que ganábamos pero
nuestras proyecciones eran erradas
suerte a guillermo lasso su éxito será
el de ecuador sólo le pido que ese es el
love que destruye vidas y familias el
consejo nacional electoral emitirá los
resultados oficiales finales el próximo
miércoles ahora la zona tendrá que hacer
frente a la crisis económica del país
agravada por la pandemia del cobi 19 y
dar un nuevo rumbo político a ecuador